as an enhancer you cannot touch caramel  because Marsh there's no such thing as a  marshmallow drizzle caramel drizzle  that's fancy [ __ ]  on top of the sweet potatoes at  Thanksgiving I'm a full marshmallow you  dumb [ __ ] that's what I'm saying  right it's an enhancement no but not  like stand up so I can hear you when  you're talking out of your [ __ ]  because it's [ __ ] you could do this  weekly with this dumb piece of [ __ ] what  a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's a functioning idiot I  can't [ __ ] people is he battery  operated he needs to be [ __ ] rebooted  he needs to be rebooted because there's  something wrong with your dumb friend  Jesus Christ taste buds it tastes done  I'm sorry what were you saying oh God  was you summed up my feelings over 100  episodes  everything I think can feel every week